I think that genes are super super hard
to shop for certain brands run larger
run smaller it's hard for me to find my
size and stores which is kind of it
doesn't really make sense because I feel
like there are a lot of people who
probably run my size there's the whole
thing with vanity sizing where companies
will make their clothes bigger so that
you'll be happier in them I want to know
what size I'm buying I don't want it
like I you're not fooling me I'm wearing
the J Brand Jeans they feel real tight
right now
I got him zipped so that's the important
part then I'm also like freshly baked
muffin tops for sale these are the
forever 21 jeans as you can see they fit
me at the waist and nowhere else these
are made of spandex so like it fits good
like right now but like it about
well-aware and a half they're gonna be
like Hammer pants I don't know man
they don't even they don't even go up
the first button the first button they
are from Alexa Chung if you don't know
who that is she's very thin they're two
hundred and thirty five dollar pants and
they fit very poorly
these are awful like really don't fit
anywhere they're like simultaneously too
small and too big they're like a little
too tight here and then like literally
too big everywhere else
these fit kind of tight but they're
supposed to they fit better
they give me more room in my butt so
that's cool it's crazy that these out of
all of them fit in there 30 bucks
these are the ones from Old Navy they
are terrible I've discovered that I can
do this you know so not successful
it kind of it really hurt my psyche
trying these on it was just weird that
they all fit differently and they fit
different body types and so it basically
reiterates how hard it is to go Jean
shopping and hopefully this will make
people feel like they're not alone when
it comes to it because it is really
really awful overall I would say that's
what's even worse than I thought it
would be I think that sometimes people
think that you want to buy clothes that
are a certain size and like that'll make
you feel better but to be honest it's
just confusing just size things away
with their size
[Music]
sweet security sensors still on this